we must be accountable that if we're
talking big game our actions have to
match our mouth I'm focused on attention
and accountability most people in this
room have not been accountable to
executing against your big words and I
searched Twitter X and all the other
platforms and I see a lot of people here
commenting about what they're doing at
this conference and what they're up to
and when I read it a lot of people here
are talking big game a lot of you were
talking about building huge companies
and you're going to be massive and
you're going to build big stuff and then
when I click on that account and try to
find what they're doing on the internet
they're producing very little content we
must be accountable that if we're
talking big game our actions have to
match our
mouth